hello and welcome to this video okay
this won't work I hope it doesn't play
dogan's fly high def 69 usually play
yeah anyway maybe not a big difference I
can't going to play quickly in this game
and lost the game before that that did
not load it just for those i mean
there's there are people who think i
just upload and share epic games that
are played well yeah and so on what I
don't it was just one of those games
where I felt I play a cheater from one I
don't know maybe I'm paranoid but I just
had just hated the game and I played
like a moral but it was just like you
look at the account and you know okay
this is not a normal account yeah anyway
so I rather ditch this game play a new
game he at least you play against the
human being okay check yeah I'd like to
stop d4 d5 I wonder does he have some
some wacky tactic my back right but Matt
well hope my back rank is weak my
background is weak
there is a tactic Teague takes Knight
takes Knight takes bishop takes Queen
takes rupee aide it cannot work now yeah
that was the most likely move my bishop
now takes some time to activate 27 rook
e8 but should be eight stuff like that
with white has some good space
h5 a move maybe
you move the kingdom when I cannot take
no it doesn't move the king he just
allows age form okay I'm going for that
wow he lets me take them chatting
careful so I'm going to grab here
take care try to prove that this bishop
won't be too is bad
check
Jim that's not very comfortable for what
we should be four is the next step here
or maybe yeah and I would like to keep
the Queen's on definitely 94s also I
think I go nitey form I don't think he
wants to take on e4 and give me that
Bishop that is looking right looking
right into his position down my damn
idea is to maybe play f6 and first drive
the Queen away start with this
maybe I have six next i wonder if i can
i can actually try no I cannot trap the
Queen somehow it would be funny if I
could trap the Queen oh so i am going to
be able to take on age three and i think
i will take that i can take this now
don't see why not
check
yeah my idea is to go Bishop g4 f3
Quincy for now for an attack my king is
quite safe yield okay yeah it's better
than Queen takes
so Bishop h3r and then Queen a4 may be
okay and not by now the endings should
also win so most endings at least okay
so the teachers are taking the spawn
they like to get the bishop over 25 if
possible
hmm perform it's really not making think
making life easy here really isn't
I could have played 26 maybe yeah let's
do this yeah I know but I have forever
checks am quite a bit check here maybe
or cannot force the Queen trade don't
see it at the moment check so give the
chick check White Rose I yeah will also
lose on time it should also be should be
a win III just winner there's no
perpetual okay hmm Joe I don't really
know what went wrong there i mean i
think i'll check out like at this
position before yeah here I think it's
approximately equal but yeah it says
should have played t5 very likely at
some point check I just basically typed
what I said yeah here the position is
certainly okay for me but it doesn't
need to be a worse position but it got
worse after this some night f form chat
this is a very uncomfortable position
where black has all the chances and why
it is just quite passive yeah I hear
black wins it's just a matter of being
technically precise Witcher maybe it
wasn't g5 you can certainly debate about
chat but it was it was okay the main
thing is to see that you should avoid
this night air for because after this
the pawn structure just get so
unfavorable for that Bishop yeah my
pieces can fight 44 while the ship on B
to a doesn't do anything for the
defendant here it's just very very
annoying those two pieces are strong the
king is weak and the white queen is very
limited and you can just give this check
then and TM I just win the porn I mean
okay Bishop f3 wasn't forced but it is a
very uncomfortable position to play I
think it's especially for you in player
quite quite awkward to defend okay well
thanks for watching